passed by hundreds of students everyday
sitting in a box at the end of hallway
in a university building in London is
the corpse of one of the most important
philosophers in modern history do remem
was a philosopher he's considered the
the father of utilitarianism the notion
that you want to do the most good for
the largest number of people he was also
a man well ahead of his time well women
were still being persecuted for
witchcraft in other parts of Europe
Jeremy Bentham was espousing things like
gay rights the end of slavery the end of
child labor animal rights he was a guy
who was forward-thinking and when it
came time for his death he didn't want
to be buried he wanted to be made into
an auto icon Jeremy Bentham wrote his
will when he was 21 and he already knew
what he wanted to happen when he died
his body was given to his friend to
dissect so that he might learn something
from it he then also wanted to be made
into a corpse that he thought maybe his
friends would come and visit that could
be taken out at parties and he did this
for a number of reasons one he didn't
have a real high view of the church and
in some ways this was a way of kind of
thumbing his nose at the religious
traditions second as a utilitarian he
genuinely thought what is the most value
that my dead body could possibly have
and finally he was just funny he was
just a funny guy who probably thought
that this was hilarious
these are the reasons he decided he
wanted himself made into a auto-icon
in fact he used to carry around a set of
glass eyes that he wanted put into his
auto-icon
and he would bring them to parties and
he'd pull them out and sort of use them
as a conversation piece and as a way of
shocking some of the more proper people
at the party the same friend who
dissected him also did the mummification
of his head he did so using a maori
style of mummification that involves
stretching and heating and i think using
hot sulphur but it looked
pretty bad with sunken cheeks the skin
is sort of tight over the skull it's not
a super great look
of course they still you know dutifully
like popped those glass eyes in there
here's the solution we're gonna have a
beautiful wax head made for him it's
gonna look just like him it's gonna be
nice and fleshy faced like he was in
life for a long time he sat there serene
wax head real head down beneath his feet
ghoulishly looking out with he's like
very bright glass eyes however in the
70s some students managed to just
extract the head the real head which
they then ransomed to the college asking
for a hundred pounds given to a charity
the university said we'll give ten
pounds to the charity and the students
dutifully returned the head after this
prank they decided to keep it somewhere
safer than between the feet of Bentham
so it is now in a victorian bell jar in
a box that takes four keys and two
people to open and no one's gonna open
it for you that said Bentham's auto-icon
it does get around he was taken out for
the 150th anniversary of the college and
he recently attended the retirement of a
particularly long servant Provost and
when they had to take him to a
conservator in another part of London
they just put him in a car they just
drove him there in the passenger seat
weekend at Bernie's style there are some
other stories of pranks that are happen
one of the most famous is that his head
was then stolen and used in a football
game this is a total myth for no other
reason than basically his real head
could never have survived some students
did steal the wax head in the 90s and
take some pictures of themselves hanging
out with it as a utilitarian I think
Bentham asked himself what good can my
corpse do and having had it dissected
having had it appear at various
functions having it serviced just an
amusing backdrop for the students of
University College London I think you
can't get a whole lot more utility
out of a dead body than that that -
there's a particularly weird Twitter
stream related to Jeremy Bentham that
you should follow there's a little
camera hooked up which takes a picture
every hour or so and sends a stream of
basically what Jeremy Bentham sees it's
like the Jeremy Bentham camp it's
strangely hypnotic and I highly suggest
you follow at panopticon stream and you
know see through the through the eyes of
Bentham himself